hi what are you doing down there
oh no no no no hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back to SCP
containment breach I know it said it
wasn't gonna be too long between
episodes but things got kind of busy but
I'm back and it's time to continue
exploring the world that we have waiting
for us but the question is where am I
I don't fully remember where I was oh
that's right I came over here to visit
the doodads but I wasn't able to get any
of the doodads
out of there I have some goodies hmm
I have some things I can you explain
that what happened like seeing did you
see what happened cuz I did not see what
happened please explain to me I'm
guessing it must have spawned around the
corner and I didn't see it before I died
okay so now that we know that let's just
head back we need to give back to the
hub and then kind of explore around keep
finding different places that we can go
to we've let out the dragons which is
very nice very nice indeed very nice but
not going to help us I might have to
save around every single gosh darn
doorway
well it's info have turned off all the
Tesla gates I know that probably not the
best idea considering that the old man
is still out there somewhere
staff offices I don't need to go there
let's just go back to the core room and
let's find another avenue that we
haven't gone down yet
let's hope that we won't run into
another sudden spawn of Billy okay so we
made it back to the core room now we
need to we just need to go around and we
need to find another area to go down I
think I'm safe in the core area I think
I would be safe I'm pretty sure I'm safe
in the core area in nine one four one
four nine nine and secure storage
I believe I've gone down here before
nine one four let me look up what nine
one four is again yeah
that is the that's the machine yeah I've
gone down there CP one seven 365 oh
that's where I came from what was six
five oh I haven't seen sixty five oh I
still haven't gotten a security card let
me go back to the first area where it
came from I haven't gone back here in a
bit and I have not seen six five zero
yet so I just need to go back and I need
to see if there's something that's
actually there to get because I don't
have a key card and it's not like there
are places that need key cards for some
reason it's not like original SCP
containment breach but if there's
something that I missed I want to find
it okay okay oh yes I remember this
nightmare yes I remember this okay but
was there anything in here that I
overlooked let me just close myself in
here just in case there's something
wants to eat my face okay wow wow wow
wow w ID in my face something why D my
face okay where the hell
oh okay oh my god okay what was in here
was I don't know what was in there I
don't know I I don't know I don't know I
don't know what the deal is with that
that is unfortunate crap hey hey hello I
don't know where I am where am i oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh
that's not good open up
Oh put a large bandage right I love that
lard bandage on this large bin douche Oh
God I was a savage feral mom friend
Murphy I thought it growled at me which
was just very bizarre I was not
expecting a growl hey what are you doing
down there at weirdo forgetting weird
okay I can make this Frick I all right I
can make this all right I can make this
okay okay okay yeah yeah yeah no no no
no no okay where am i where am i where
am i where am i where am i what is what
where is this what is this well this is
not even open okay have I been here
before I don't remember
oh no oh you oh no oh God
I knew it I knew it I knew it I mean of
course I knew it what else is there no
bird you're gonna be following me the
whole goddamn game now well that's the
thing now then I have to deal with hey
buddy I don't worry about anything
you're just a sweet little tot now
you're sweet you sweet summer child
though you're still here Oh God oh don't
get in the way my door not getting the
way in my door you can hang around you
can join me on my adventures but you do
not get to get in the way of my door
okay
perfectly acceptable I feel like these
rules are fair and everyone who can be a
part of it is understanding and
cooperative weirdo okay where did I just
spring from I was coming from over here
I don't think going back is gonna do me
anything but I'm just backtracking
because ya know there was really nothing
here that I could have gotten I don't
think that there would have been
anything that I would have overlooked oh
hi what are you doing down there oh no
no no no oh god okay okay that is not
cool that is so not cool
oh my god that's not cool that is not
cool that's not cool that's not cool was
that supposed to happen when I opened
the blast doors for the first time is
that what that was supposed to happen I
didn't do that I didn't do that at all
actually I didn't do none of that good
god you dick these guys are being real
uppity okay back to the core hi oh this
game really likes to give you the
business really loves that one 762
that's where I just came from that's the
other one so I got to go to a different
sublevel is the thing let me go down
what I'm what I don't even know what
sublevel I'm on is there another level
below no there's not this one just has
the blood and the
yes oh hi hey bud how you doing good to
see you ah where are you fine it's
totally fine
good to know you're following me I need
to go back to sublevel one there's
something apparently that I missed in
the Security office it's the place where
I shut down all the Tesla gates which is
good I'm assuming I'm guessing that's
what I wanted to do but I don't want to
do is I don't want to walk into this
hallway and then be accosted by numerous
thing this that want to eat me okay here
we go
no new cluster never mind okay
I still don't know if it's the best idea
to leave the doors open all good no I'm
fine everything's fine
why wouldn't everything be fine I don't
know sure are a lot of rumors they keep
this place nice and clean all the blood
off the floor so far so smooth so far so
smooth journey so far no douche bags
want to bother me so far so good
so far so good can you get me through
that door can you get me through the
door I don't think you can get me
through the door what does this sign say
you know take his burger really Skyrim
cafeteria okay this is a problem hey bud
hey why why must you be dick why must
you be dick sure chased me through all
the ways I just came
now you gonna be now you're gonna get it
now you could get it oh god your sludge
I forgot about your sludge oh no no no
no no please please please oh no you
done you done being a douche you done
and won 7-3 are you done
occupying the one room I needed you both
done can you both please be done please
I am asking nicely
oh god damn you damn you damn you damn
you okay No okay I was about to say I
was about to say
okay so there's apparently a locker in
here with a key card in it there's a
medical hype oh that's good I need that
okay I guess I don't there's some kind
of a key key head SCP level one I can't
believe I never found that before how
did I not get the security memo all
right whatever I have it now so all I
gotta do is I gotta go back and then I
can free one seven why well that's
problem
hey hey bud hey bud I don't like your
bloody tripod it's no boy no no boy no
no boy no indeed okay not a problem not
a problem not a problem not a problem
old hat at this point old hat it's
basically a straight shot I just I think
it's down on the Y oh hey bud okay
problem oh wow you got an orchestra with
you
that's fantastic hey can I squeeze by
here skate you thanks bud thanks bud bud
thanks crud bud thanks crud crud bud bud
thanks bud thank you love you and all
that you do okay moving on
when did we what what is it's gonna be
unannounced he's gonna be there only now
it's not announced oh well I'm not
blinky I wasn't ready okay here we go
blinky okay mind if I squeeze by why
well you do have fun you do have fun you
you two you two peas in a pod if ever
there were one or two okay well this is
horrifying and I need to go down to
sublevel three again I believe now
arriving at or was it this one was it
sublevel two it might have been sublevel
two let me just take a quick look yeah
one three one okay I need to get to one
three one it's where I started this damn
episode all right let's do this
I'm on the way baby I'm about to unleash
some new SCPs
scps that I have never seen before
should be fun okay we made it okay
shockingly we made it without incident
okay hey buds hey hey how you doing are
you doing little Boise's oh damn oh look
it's like do big eyes this is incredible
all right come on little buddies what if
what if they get locked behind a door am
I gonna have to like be aware of that oh
no come on come on path find
don't like that come on bud come on you
can do it there you go
all right buds you come on oh you cute
whoa
are you watching him okay I'm gonna
blink I'm gonna blink I'm blinking oh
whoa Wow it works it works it works
oh it works it works oh it works baby oh
it works hey come on guys let's go come
on guys let's go let's go let's go let's
go mmm oh you ugly oh you ugly uh-huh
all right are you guys just gonna be
there forever now have you guys got him
trapped there like for the whole game is
that what you do no thank you
thank you little guys thank you okay
one seven three has been effectively
contained baby
all right well Halle hell I never
thought that it would be that way am i
does that mean I'm free have I beaten
the game I really don't know how much
more there is to the game I you got to
remember this you can't kill me because
I don't want it I don't go don't consent
oh that's a fun tactic all right no yeah
I hit I hit safe zone I wanted to go
back a little bit because there were
staff officers over here that I don't
know that I went into but yeah this game
is still in early early access it's
still in way alpha they've got a lot of
stuff here and they got a lot of polish
and they got a lot of good stuff going
on but at the same time it is still
early on I do not know how much more
content content that there is but hey I
freed the little dudes that's pretty
cool yeah I think I'm gonna end this one
here with that little bit of success
that I got and in the safety and
sanctity of this office area so thank
you everybody so much for watching
probably when there's another update to
the game unless
there's something amazing that I'm
missing in this version of the game let
me know in the comments if I am but
probably when there's another update to
the game I will play this again you can
rest assured of that I've been playing
this game well versions of this games
it's the beginning of my channel it's
crazy to think that I'm still playing it
eight years later so thank you and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]